>> YOU CANNOT BE CIVIL.
YOU CANNOT BE CIVIL.
>> STEVE: YOU CANNOT.
THIS WEEK THERE IS A NEW TWIST
IN THE ELITIST DEMOCRATS HATE
FILLED CAMPAIGN TO DIVIDE
AMERICA.
MISSUS CLINTON SAID IT WAS OKAY
BECAUSE REPUBLICANS ARE NOT JUST
WRONG, THEY'RE EVIL.
GO AHEAD, KEEP GOING WITH THE
RAGE AND HATE.
KEEP GOING WITH THIS.
>> AND ALSO THIS.
>> KEEP GOING WITH STATEMENTS
LIKE THIS FROM THE SENIOR GOOGLE
EXECUTIVE.
QUOTE, YOU ARE FINISHED GOP, YOU
POLISH THE FINAL NAIL FOR YOUR
OWN COFFINS.
F YOU ALL TO HELL.
I HOPE THE LAST IMAGE IS BURNED
INTO YOUR SLIMY EVIL, MILLIONS
WOMEN LAUGHING, CELEBRATING.
I CAN'T FINISH THAT.
KEEP GOING SHE SAID WITH
CAMPAIGN ADS LIKE THIS ONE.
ENCOURAGING YOUNG PEOPLE.
>> TAX CUTS FOR THE RICH, HELL
YEAH.
>> CLIMATE CHANGE?
THE SEE YOU PROBLEM.
I'LL BE DEAD SOON.
>> IS JUST SO OFFENSIVE.
AND IT WASN'T JUST MISSUS
CLINTON.
OTHER ESTABLISHED DEMOCRATS.
>> MICHELLE SAYS WHEN THEY GO
THOUGH WE GO HI, NO, WHEN THEY
GO LOW, WE KICK THEM.
>> STEVE: WE KICK THEM.
NOW THEY'RE BLAMING THE ANGER
AND HATE ON PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
HIS SUPPORTERS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS BLAME
SHIFTING OVER AT MSNBC.
>> NOW, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS HOLDING RALLIES
WERE ANGRY MONTHS OF PEOPLE ARE
DEMANDING TO LOCK UP THE UNITED
STATES SENATOR BECAUSE THEY
DISAGREE WITH HER POLITICS.
>> HANG ON.
THERE'S A MASSIVE DIFFERENCE,
TRUMP SUPPORTERS ANGERS ANGRY
WITH POLITICIANS LIKE HILLARY
CLINTON AND DIANE FEINSTEIN.
THE RIGHT TO BE ANGRY.
AS THE POLITICIANS ANGRY WITH
THE PEOPLE.
GOOD OLD MISSUS CLINTON STARTED
IT.
>> TO JUST BE GROSSLY
JOURNALISTIC, YOU COULD PUT HALF
OF TRUMP SUPPORTERS OF WHAT I
CALL THE BASKET OF DEPLORABLE.
RIGHT?
THE RACIST, SEXIST, HOMOPHOBIC,
XENOPHOBIC, IS THE HOMOPHOBIC --
>> STEVE: GROSSLY AS THE WORLD.
NOW, NEW GENERATION OF DEMOCRATS
IS GETTING IN ON THE HEATING
GANG.
>> YOU ARE EITHER COMPLICIT IN
THE EVIL, YOU'RE EITHER
CONTRIBUTING TO THE WRONG OR
FIGHTING AGAINST IT.
>> COMPLICIT IN EVIL, WHO TALKS
LIKE THAT?
OLD-TIMERS ARE GETTING INTO IT.
THEY CAN'T BEAR TO BE LEFT OUT.
>> THEY, NOT YOU HAVE AN ALLY IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THIS TIME, THEY HAVE AN ALLY.
IT'S A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
VERLYN PEOPLE.
>> THE DREGS OF SOCIETY.
THAT'S WHAT THEY THINK OF YOU.
THESE ELITIST DEMOCRATS WANT TO
BE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
HERE'S A HINT.
YOU'LL NEVER, EVER BECOME
PRESIDENT IF YOU HATE THE